hank goldberg back on the Rich Eisen
sure what's up Hank well happy
Anniversary to start with I remember
when you were courting Suze
unsuccessfully when you were when she
was working with you Hank we were
friends back then but yes you Hank she
loves you Hank and wanted me to say to
you yeah thank you
all right let's get into your pics Hank
what do you have for me here for the
Belmont Stakes well you know iceberg is
the hot horse he's probably gonna be
four to one this is Bill Mott I was
talking to Nick Zito about this and
Hochberg is adopted the same kind of
training regimen that nicked it when he
upset Smarty Jones years ago and that he
had a rough trip in the Derby and Maude
took him up to Saratoga and that's where
he's kept them and he's had some
tremendous workouts up there and he's
coming into the race he's bred to go to
distance he was the wiseguy horse in the
Derby and he got knocked around two or
three times and he still wound up
finishing seventh and I like him and I
think he's he's the one horse that I
think could upset justified not justify
I said the next what do you think Nick
said and I agree with him he said the
negatives would justify are that he's
coming out of a very tiring race on a
very tiring racetrack and he's had five
races in a very short period of time and
so he could be a little weary and I said
what's the positive he said he's the
best horse that always does help but I
like I like Hochberg I like justify and
I like blended citizen number ten the
one problem he has is that he has a West
Coast rider on him we've had limited
experience although he did ride him in
the Peter Pan man he he's gonna ride him
again but he's had very little
experience at Belmont and that is always
a negative in that they always misjudged
that long run
down the backstretch that's what
happened to Stuart Elliot years ago and
when he had a favor in the race but
plant citizen is stepping up in
competition but he really finished
strong in the Peter Pan has the right
kind of running style and I think he
could hit the port so my exacta box is 1
4 and 10 and the other horse I'm going
to use is vino rosso vino rosso is
trained by Todd Fletcher who's won three
of these he had a outside post in the
Derby never really had a chance to run
his race and he didn't wipe that off
track and it may rain a little bit on
Saturday but nonetheless the problem I
had with vino rosso is he won the would
but he beat up real bad group of horses
and I don't think he's up to beating
this group's all right well I use them
underneath okay so I'm looking at the
weather here maybe you've got a better
weather report than me it doesn't look
like let's put it this way they won't be
as sloppy as the tracks that justify is
won the first two races any concern on
that front for the Triple Crown hopes no
okay but I just think I had the same
feeling addicted I thought that that
race took a lot out of them although I
didn't think that proviso was I thought
that was kind of a fluke that he almost
caught him and that Mike Smith was
engaged in that speed too early and he
went up on a horse at the beginning of
the stretch and there were the
visibility was so bad that he didn't see
Proviso coming and that's why he almost
got beat he's a much better horse than
bravado so okay and I think Wayne's
worse since third Triple Crown race he
could have weary legs so one for 10 as
your exacta box and then you're gonna
throw the 8 in just for good measure no
for the super pack for the superfecta ok
good ok so one for 10 a minute for the
superfecta that's what I'm gonna get
some fava beans before I watched Jodie
Foster nice you have a nice Chianti
already yeah I got the job ok fantastic
thank you the best thanks for the call
ok good luck tomorrow
yeah you too hopefully we'll check back
in with them on
Monday we'll do it a bit I don't we'll
get the signer as he likes to put it
right because of the odds of justify and
then HOF Byrd I mean those are those
aren't the best odds the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience